speaking of like inspiring artists you
inspired so many artists um and i know
billy eilish olivia rodrigo like those
are huge artists right now that i love
as well as a ton of people do but they
all credit to you like for being one of
their idols that they like listened to
and loved have you ever talked with them
um first of all it's like so crazy to
hear that and it's like it's like so
flattering and um yeah i've had the
chance to meet
billy and olivia and they're like
they're both so incredible and i love
what they're doing their songwriting
they're like
they're just so like creatively talented
and yeah i've had the chance to meet
both of them they're both very raw which
i think you were as well like whenever
you first started too like and still now
but i just mean i think that's what
people
loved about you you're very honest about
it regardless of what you were saying
and i think that people really love
that's why i like when i grew up with
like alanis i felt like atlantis was
that for me like i yeah i love that she
was just honest about it and i think
that that's true for olivia and billy
and you know them giving you credit for
having you know kind of being a puttier
for them yeah and the sense of feeling
like they could own that and say it and
be honest is really cool it is really
cool yeah i love what they're doing like
they're so young and they're songwriters
and i feel like they're like not like
they're just like being so raw and
sincere and like writing from their
experiences and that's why like people
are relating to their music and i think
when you're that young too you don't
really think about like how big the
career could be how many people could be
it's just like therapy
yeah for sure and i feel like that's
kind of like what my vibe was too like i
had no idea what was gonna happen to me
in my life or like how big my first
record would be but
yeah for sure
[Music]
you